Ja, herzlich willkommen.
Heute geht es um Tomaten.
Und zwar nicht um die Tomaten, die man im
Beet oder im Gewächshaus anbauen kann, sondern
um Topftomaten.
Also wenn du im Topf oder Kübel auf dem Balkon
oder auf der Terrasse Tomaten anbauen möchtest,
dann bist du hier genau richtig, ich werde
dir nämlich jetzt zeigen, wie das funktioniert.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach, Tomaten im Topf
so anzubauen, dass sie wirklich kräftig werden
und richtig Ertrag abwerfen.
Und deswegen teile ich heute elf Tipps mit
dir, die deinen Tomaten zu neuen Höchstformen
verhelfen sollen.
Also los geht’s, komm mit!
Tipp Nummer eins ist, dass deine Tomaten einen
richtig großen Topf brauchen.
Das ist der häufigste Fehler, den ich sehe,
wenn Leute Tomaten im Topf anbauen, dass sie
einen viel zu kleinen Topf nehmen.
Da haben die Tomaten überhaupt keine Chance,
richtig groß und kräftig zu werden und ganz,
ganz viele Tomaten zu produzieren.
Also ganz so groß wie meiner muss der Topf
nicht sein, aber zwanzig Liter sollte der
mindestens fassen, damit deine Tomaten überhaupt
das Zeug haben oder die Grundlage haben, um
richtig gut zu produzieren.
Tipp Nummer zwei ist, dass deine Tomaten hungrig
sind.
Deswegen baue ich meine Tomaten am allerliebsten
in reinem Kompost an.
Den kann man ja im Garten selber machen, ist
immer noch cooler irgendwie, als fertige Tomatenerde
zu kaufen.
Das würde aber natürlich auch gehen.
Und am allerliebsten verwende ich dafür verrotteten
Hühnermistkompost.
Das hat den Grund, dass in Hühnermist ganz
viel Phosphor und Stickstoff enthalten ist
und die Tomaten sich da drin natürlich noch
umso wohler fühlen (lacht), weil das sind
zwei Sachen, auf die die total stehen.
Ja, damit fülle ich also die untere Hälfte
meines Topfes, und dann gebe ich ein bis zwei
Hände Sand dazu und vermische das Ganze gut.
Das mache ich deswegen, damit das Wasser besser
abfließen kann, damit die Tomaten nicht so
nasse Füße bekommen, das mögen die nämlich
nicht.
Und so habe ich im unteren Teil des Topfes
dann noch so ein bisschen eine lockerere Erde,
wo Wasser ein bisschen besser ablaufen kann
als im oberen Bereich.
Das hat sich bei uns sehr gut bewährt, das
so zu machen.
Tipp Nummer drei ist, dass du in jeden Topf
wirklich nur eine Tomatenpflanze setzen solltest.
Das ist deswegen wichtig, weil die sich sonst
gegenseitig Konkurrenz machen und nie so groß
und kräftig werden, wie sie eigentlich werden
könnten.
Deswegen.
Das machen auch aber ganz viele Leute, gerade,
wenn die noch so klein sind, dann traut man
denen ja auch gar nicht zu, wie groß die
mal irgendwann werden, dass sie dann zwei
oder sogar drei Tomaten in einen Topf pflanzen.
Das machen wir nicht.
Das kannst du machen, wenn du Maurerkübel
verwendest zum Tomatenpflanzen, da passen
dann schonmal zwei oder sogar drei Tomaten
in einen Kübel, aber wenn du die im Topf
anbaust, dann immer nur eine Pflanze pro Topf.
Ganz wichtig.
Ich habe ja letztens schonmal ein Video über
Tomaten gemacht.
Da ging es um Freilandtomaten und Tomaten,
die man ins Gewächshaus pflanzt, das kann
ich euch gerne nochmal da oben verlinken,
und da habe ich euch ja meine geheime Düngermixtur
vorgestellt.
Die kommt jetzt auch wieder zum Einsatz.
Das sind einmal Hornspäne, einmal Magnesiumsulfat
und einmal Urgesteinsmehl zu gleichen Anteilen.
Und die vermische ich jetzt gut miteinander,
und dann gebe ich statt zwei Esslöffeln diesmal
drei Esslöffel pro Pflanze in den Topf und
vermische das auch wieder mit der unteren
Hälfte, die wir schon gefüllt haben, also
mit dem Kompost, so dass die Tomaten gut mit
Dünger und allem, was sie brauchen, versorgt
sind fürs Erste.
Man muss dann später schon auch noch düngen,
das erzähle ich euch auch gleich noch, wie
das geht, aber das hier ist eine super Starthilfe.
Also die Sachen kann ich euch wieder in der
Infobox verlinken, wenn ihr schauen wollt,
was ich da benutze, und davon gebe ich jetzt
drei Esslöffel pro Pflanze in den Topf, und
dann einmal richtig gut umrühren.
Ja, und dann kommen wir zu Tipp Nummer fünf.
Jetzt pflanzen wir die Tomaten, und dann ist
es ganz wichtig, dass ihr die unteren Blätter,
die den Boden berühren, abknipst.
Die Tomaten werden immer ein bisschen tiefer
gesetzt, als sie im Topf stehen, so dass sie
noch mehr Wurzeln bilden können und noch
fester stehen, und da könnt ihr ruhig ordentlich
viel von eurem Pflänzchen abknipsen und die
schön (lacht) tief in die Erde stecken und
alle Blätter, die dann hinterher noch den
Boden berühren, auch einfach abmachen.
Das ist ganz wichtig, weil die Pflanzen sehr
anfällig sind für die Krautfäule, die kommt
vom Boden auf die Blätter hoch, und deswegen
sollten die Blätter niemals den Boden berühren.
Wenn ihr euch übrigens fragt, welche Sorten
wir anbauen, kann ich euch auch gerne ein
Video hier oben verlinken, wo ich meine fünf
allerliebsten Tomatensorten vorstelle.
Es gibt ja tausende Tomatensorten, die alle
ganz toll sind und alle ganz unterschiedlich
sind, und wenn ihr euch da mal inspirieren
lassen wollt, dann klickt gerne da oben.
Ich werde jetzt in die Töpfe die Sorte Zuckertraube
pflanzen, eine sehr tolle Cherry-Tomaten,
die super lecker ist und die wir immer wieder
gerne anbauen, die auch relativ freilandtauglich
ist, das heißt, selbst wenn es mal ein bisschen
nass wird hier auf der Terrasse oder auf dem
Balkon, dann macht die nicht gleich schwach.
Also Tomaten sind ja sehr empfindlich, und
wir haben die schon sehr erfolgreich hier
am Haus im Kübel angebaut oder im Topf und
auch schon im Freiland im Beet.
Also eine tolle Sorte, wenn man Tomaten auf
der Terrasse oder auf dem Balkon anbauen möchte.
Tipp Nummer sechs ist: Deine Tomaten brauchen
irgendeine Form von Rankhilfe.
Das kann ein ganz normaler Tomatenstab sein,
das kann aber auch ein Stock sein. der sollte
lang genug sein, dass die Tomaten da lang
dran hochwachsen können, also um die zwei
Meter wäre nicht schlecht.
Den versenkst du dann ganz tief in deinem
Topf, damit er einen guten Stand hat und auch
die Pflanze stützen kann, und dann kannst
du die Pflanze da immer wieder dran hochbinden.
Also ich mache dann immer eine lockere Schlaufe
um den Stil der Pflanze drum rum, am besten
unter einem Blattpaar, so dass die Pflanze
weiter nach oben wachsen kann, ohne, dass
dieses Seil ihr im Weg ist.
Und dann kannst du sie daran immer wieder
festbinden, wenn du merkst, dass sie oben
schon ein bisschen nachgewachsen ist und wackelig
wird, damit sie nicht abbricht, weil das ist
super schade.
Wenn dieser Haupttrieb hier abbricht bei Tomaten,
dann hat man ein Problem, weil dann kann sie
nicht mehr weiterwachsen.
Dann kann man zwar noch einen Geiztrieb nach
oben leiten und den als zweiten Haupttrieb
etablieren, aber das ist immer ein bisschen
umständlich und nervig.
Ist besser, wenn es nicht passiert.
Tipp Nummer sieben: Deine Tomaten brauchen
einen absolut sonnigen Platz, mindestens fünf
Stunden Sonne, sonst brauchst du es gar nicht
erst versuchen.
Besser sind sieben Stunden.
Und das ist super, super wichtig.
Also suche dir einen schönen, sonnigen Ort
für deine Tomaten aus.
Und dann kommen wir auch schon zu Tipp Nummer
acht: Das bedeutet auf dem Balkon, im Topf
oder im Kübel baut man am besten kleinfrüchtige
Sorten wie zum Beispiel Cherry- oder Cocktailtomaten
an, weil die, auch wenn es mal nicht so sonnig
ist oder wenn mehr Schatten auf den Balkon
fällt, immer noch gut Früchte produzieren,
die kommen mit den fünf Stunden Sonnenlicht
also ganz gut zurecht, wohingegen große Fleischtomaten
wie zum Beispiel die Ananastomate auf dem
Balkon nicht so gute Chancen hätten, ihre
Früchte dann auch ausreifen zu lassen, wenn
da nicht den ganzen Tag Sonne drauf knallt.
Und wenn du deine Pflanzen dann gepflanzt
hast, dann kommt Tipp Nummer neun: Du musst
deine Tomaten, wenn du sie im Topf anbaust,
regelmäßig gießen.
Regelmäßige Feuchtigkeit oder gleichbleibende
Feuchtigkeit ist bei Tomaten sowieso ganz
wichtig, und im Topf kann ganz viel Gießwasser
immer wieder verdunsten.
Das kann man kaum verhindern, und deswegen
ist es ganz wichtig, dass du die regelmäßig
gießt.
Manche Leute sagen, die muss man nur so einmal
in der Woche gießen, ich finde das aber zu
wenig.
Also die Erde sollte nie komplett austrocknen,
deswegen gießen wir unsere Tomaten, wenn
wir dran denken, jeden Tag im Topf.
Wenn es mal einen Tag nicht klappt, ist das
auch nicht dramatisch, aber spätestens alle
drei Tage sollten die ordentlich Gießwasser
bekommen, damit sie, ja, zufrieden sind in
ihrem Topf, weil der eben super schnell austrocknet.
Und dann kommt auch schon Tipp Nummer zehn,
passend dazu: Dass du deine Tomaten nämlich
mulchen solltest, auch im Topf.
Ihr wisst, ich bin ein großer Mulch-Fan,
ich kann euch gerne nochmal ein Video hier
oben verlinken, wo ich euch erzähle, wie
viel Arbeit uns Mulch in unserem Garten erspart,
und das gilt genauso im Topf.
Gerade da, weil es eben so schnell austrocknet,
ist es super wichtig, dass man die oberste
Erdschicht mit einer organischen Schicht abdeckt.
Wir benutzen dafür Rasenschnitt oder Holzhackschnitzel,
da kannst du auch Stroh für nehmen, und das
macht wirklich einen enormen Unterschied,
wenn es darum geht, dass der Topf schön feucht
bleibt.
Also auch Topftomaten richtig dick mulchen.
Da kannst du ruhig zehn oder 15 Zentimeter
organisches Material draufpacken, das ist
gar kein Problem.
Tipp Nummer elf, ich habe es euch versprochen,
sprechen wir nochmal über die Düngung, wenn
deine Tomaten denn dann gepflanzt sind.
Da mache ich es so, dass ich entweder einen
biologischen Tomatendünger verwende, es gibt
ja tolle Dünger, die genau auf Tomaten abgestimmt
sind, da kann ich euch auch gerne einen in
die Infobox packen, ansonsten stehen Tomaten
auch unglaublich auf Brennnesseljauche.
Ja, die stinkt ein bisschen, kommt drauf an,
wie man die so herstellt, ob die ganz arg
stinkt oder nur ein bisschen, aber da freuen
sich auch Topftomaten drüber.
Muss man sich überlegen, ob man das auf dem
Balkon machen will.
Deswegen ist ein biologischer Tomatendünger
natürlich auch super, den kann man im Gießwasser
verdünnen und die Tomaten dann damit gießen.
Und dann sind sie mit allem versorgt, was
sie für ein glückliches Tomatenleben brauchen.
Damit kannst du die dann alle drei Wochen
düngen, entweder mit Brennnesseljauche oder
mit einem biologischen Tomatendünger, auch
mal beides abwechselnd ist auch nicht schlecht,
da freuen sich dann deine Tomaten drüber.
Damit wünsche ich euch eine dicke, fette
Tomatenernte!
Wenn euch das Video gefallen oder weitergeholfen
hat, dann gebt ihm gerne einen Daumen nach
oben, das hilft mir und meinem Kanal ungemein.
Lasst auch gerne ein Abo da.
Wir haben noch viele andere Tomatenvideos
geplant dieses Jahr.
Wenn ihr wissen wollt, wie es weitergeht,
wie man die zum Beispiel ausgeizt oder wie
man die den Sommer über pflegt, dann tragt
euch gerne da unten ein, es kommt auch irgendwann
sicher ein Tomatensaucenrezept zum Einkochen.
Ja, und teil das Video gerne mit deinen Freunden.
Wenn du Freunde hast, die auch dieses Jahr
Tomaten im Topf anbauen wollen, und denen
das Video weiterhelfen könnte, dann würde
ich mich super arg darüber freuen.
Da drüben findest du ein Video, in dem ich
dir erzähle, wie du Tomaten auch im Freiland
oder im Gewächshaus anbauen kannst, und da
unten verlinke ich dir auch ein Video, das
dich interessieren könnte.
Vielleicht sehen wir uns ja da drüben wieder.
Bis dann!
Bis nächste Woche!
Macht es gut!
Tschüss!